Her low freak bitches.
So this the vidcon thing that you went to,
what,
who puts this together?
Hank and John Green.
And who are they?
The vlog brothers.
They're famous youtubers.
And uh,
I find it very interesting when it needs,
who is calling me a shithead and garbage human and that's a direct violation of
our code of conduct.
And did they do anything about it?
No,
because she's a feminist because she's a woman.
Oh.
Because she gets special cause she was in Esaw keys and because she gets special
treatment because at this point she's basically become the avatar feminism.
If she fails,
I swear to God I didn't know what I mean.
Is she respected in that world?
No.
No,
no.
Everyone hates her.
Why did they still proper up?
Because she's in his sock.
Keizan if she doesn't make any sense,
why not?
I mean,
there's a myth that's built up around to and get word.
Yes.
It's um,
and they've all propped her up.
They've all propped her up level,
said good things about him.
They've will defended her.
And if it turns out that she is in fact an abuser,
which she did according to the Vidcon code of conduct,
which is the code of conduct.
Oh,
I can't remember it verbatim,
but I write down a video.
Uh,
it's one of my latest videos.
Um,
it was just a quick message to Hank and John Green and a,
I know that thousands of people email them saying,
hey,
look,
she did violate your code of conduct from a position of institutional privilege
at Vidcon.
She was on the panel.
I didn't have a microphone.
She had a microphone.
She's calling me names.
She's accusing me of things aren't true.
She,
and she was doing that while you were in the audience directly looking me in the
eye.
And it was like,
okay,
that's fine.
But,
uh,
that's not right.
And they've done nothing.
They have done nothing.
They've said nothing.
You talk.
And then afterwards,
all I got from her fans and,
and I mean like,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of messages,
and I've just retweeted them all night with exactly the same language she uses
when she's displaying.
Oh,
look at that nasty messages.
I'm guessing of people calling me eight garbage human,
which is what she called me.
And so she has done absolutely nothing different.
And so I said,
right,
Hank and John,
she's violated your code of conduct.
Her fans,
she's incited a cyber model harassers exactly as she claims I do.
But she has actually done this.
Then on the Saturday she was due to be on a panel about cyber harassment.
See?
But it can't be harassment when she's a woman and you're a man because you are
the oppressor.
So it's the same thing as racism and the black person being raised against a
white person.
Is it possible the only reason to do this then to not to take no action is if
you are highly ideological.
And interestingly,
it's so you feel like they're high d I highly ideological.
Yeah.
Incredibly biased.
But why are they,
if they're youtube stars,
I mean,
aren't they like,
don't they understand they're very progressive,
very progressive.
But you're fairly progressive to know I'm a liberal,
I'm not progressing.
What is the difference between a liberal,
a liberal called sales opportunity?
I
progressive ones,
quality of outcome.
When I was little,
I told my dad,
I was like,
can we get rid of the apostrophe?
I was young,
I was like 12.
And he was like,
Huh.
And I was like,
it's just a sucks.
Like we're,
I feel like,
like what is it?
Like people always mispronounce it and he's like,
you should be proud of that.
And I was like,
I'm not,
and then,
and then
I remember thinking I'm not,
it's just the Boston 13 that's rough.
Yeah.
And then,
and then,
and then I started to like it,
you know,
cause I'm like,
yeah,
I guess it is my name.
Fuck it,
you know.
Uh,
but when I was little,
I wanted to change.
I remember,
I remember asking my parents if I could,
I mean,
this is embarrassing.
I remember telling my parents that I wanted to change my name to,
to Damien Monroe
from Chris Delea to Damien Damien Monroe.
Imagine.
Imagine if my name was Damian Monroe.
You would have hated me immediately.
No,
I wouldn't.
I know cause you open minded.
Yeah.
But Dave,
your field Vaughn,
that's a good tentious name ever.
My name is Theodore.
Theodore.
Vaughn but think about it.
But think about,
this is why you didn't even know why,
why I wanted to name it because this is so embarrassing.
I'm whatever.
But okay,
because Damien was is the devil,
right?
Okay.
And then Marilyn Monroe was like pure in my head,
so I was like,
you have both this.
So this was like a show Biz name Id.
I don't know.
I didn't get very far with it obviously this time.
Yeah,
same age,
like young,
what am I?
But I was like,
well I could call me.
I mean I just named myself Damien Monroe.
Oh my God.
Imagine now I would hate that.
Delirious.
I mean we all do stupid things as a kid and I didn't get to do that.
Obviously my parents wouldn't have let me do that.
Thank God I was a fucking Weirdo man.
I would ask my parents,
I would,
I would ask my peers because I always sat like this at the dinner table and I
asked him,
I was like,
can you call me crazy legs?
And I remember thinking like,
oh,
like that would be cool.
Like if my family called me crazy legs,
it's Damien crazy legs.
And then they were like,
and my dad was like,
no.
And I was like,
but just like maybe just at least at the dinner table,
I remember saying that and you'd be like,
I'm not fucking calling you crazy leg.
We need you Chris.
Oh my God.
So funny kid shit that was even younger.
The crazy legs thing.
It was like,
it was probably like a nine.
I have not,
I've never had anyone really tried to pick a fight with me.
I had a guy at a concert once,
I get all get all butthurt about me not letting it pass in between me and this,
this girl.
And it was standing with me cause people kept trying to cut through to get,
it was at anthrax and he wanted to get,
and I'm just like,
fuck this.
Why do people keep trying to walk between us?
Like Jesus just go around.
So eventually I'm like,
no,
I'm not letting anybody by.
So I got my elbows out and people would bump into it and then go,
go around.
Well,
this guy,
he just going kept tapping.
It's just like,
man,
fuck you dude.
I'm sitting here with a girl,
go away.
He was trying to give a treat and you and your girl and so a dick rob maybe.
I mean,
if he'd asked nicely,
maybe he would've got one.
Well,
I don't know.
That's a bold ask.
But uh,
you know what though?
Fortune favors the bold and I'm a kind human being.
Maybe he didn't want me to rub his dick,
but that's what he woulda got.
You would've got that to give and you take sir.
So,
uh,
the guy comes around and he finally goes around us and then he's just,
he looks at me,
he's like,
hey man,
I was trying to get through.
And I go,
look,
I'm standing here with this girl,
like,
go somewhat.
You just go around and he's getting all,
he's getting pissed about it cause I'm dismissing him,
you know,
so eventually I'm just like,
just,
you know,
let's go.
Let's walk away now.
That gets his fucking hackles up and he's all mad and he's,
he's looking at me,
he's like,
you and this and that.
And I started laughing at him.
I go,
Oh,
you want to,
you want to scrap because you can't get through here is that,
is that it is,
this is what you want to do.
And he's just like,
well,
and I go,
okay,
we'll just move on.
Oh,
fucking chest up even bigger.
And it's just like,
he looks like he's going to walk away,
whatever I'm saying,
all right.
You know?
Okay,
do your own thing.
He's like,
Ooh,
he's just getting even more looked up and funny points his finger out and I'm
laughing at him.
And the girl who,
uh,
who was,
does Jujitsu and was a fighter,
she reaches out and grabs the whole disguise risks and pulls his hand out and
she's like,
don't you don't want to do that.
And then he looks at her and he looks at me and I'm just smiling and he pulls
his hand back and I go,
I know what must have gone through his head is just like,
this girl's grip is serious.
And she's telling me,
don't fucking do it.
It's probably a good idea not to fucking do it,
probably exactly what.
But other times there have been like,
uh,
you know,
I'm not impervious to getting an a mood.
And so sometimes I've been out and about and someone was being a dickhead and I
see it and it's like,
okay,
this is,
he's,
he's clearly trying to egg something on somehow.
And so maybe I,
you know,
add a little something to that scene,
a feel if he'll,
uh,
he'll bite and just happen,
you know,
or I've had some people go,
oh yeah,
of course.
No one's going to fight you.
They know who you are.
I'm like,
are you fucking kidding me?
I'm some sort of d list celebrity.
Nobody knows who the fuck I am.
So get away with a lot.
And the thing is,
if a guy who had a fight,
he would know who you are.
Oh fuck.
I was a fan of fighting.
He would know who you are.
And those guys would be way less likely to pick a fight in the first,
there was one dude who was at this bar and Fullerton and he's being just
belligerent.
He's being an asshole and this place and,
and my buddy hammer,
he was the door guy at the time and the southern and they're like,
come on and he's,
this guy's fucking getting all riled up.
And I'm standing there with hammer and just looking at this dude.
And eventually the other tour guy comes over and he's like,
hey,
you fucking dumb ass.
You're wearing the fucking tee shirt of that guy right there.
So maybe you might want to shut the fuck up.
It's this guy's wearing one of my affliction shirts.
And the guy looks at the shirt and he looks at me and he's like,
Oh shit,
this is stupid.
Getting your ass kicked because
you picked a fight with a guy whose shirt you have on like you,
you are,
you're wearing a Josh Barnett shirt.
Yeah.